If you look at our current technological
systems near our minds are they are very
different.
And one of the biggest questions for me
is what's the difference between where
we are now and where we need to be.
If you want to build mines,
if you want to build systems that are
generally intelligent and self motivated
and maybe self aware.
And of course the answer to this we
don't know because if you knew we
already done it,
but uh,
there are basically several perspectives
on this.
One is our minds as general learning
systems that are able to waddle
arbitrary things including themselves.
And if they are this,
they probably need a very distinct set
of motivations,
needs,
um,
things that they want to do.
And I think that humans get their
specifics due to their particular needs.
We have cognitive and social and
physiological needs and they turn us on
who we are.
Our motivations determine what,
where we put our attention to and what
you learned and what we actually do in
the world.
But you model.
How about we perceive what are your
conscious of in a similar sense it might
be that it's sufficient to build a
genuine learning architecture and
combined this is a good motivational
system in beer,
not there yet that we have built a
genuine learning architecture.
For instance,
our minds can learn and create new
algorithms.
They can be used to write code and
invent code programming code for
instance,
or the rules that you need to build the
shop and ran their chop.
If you were a shopkeeper,
which is some kind of programming task
in its own right.
We don't know how to build a system that
is able to do this yet.
It involves,
for instance,
that we have systems that are able to
learn loops and you have some techniques
to do this.
For instance,
a long short term memory and a few other
tricks,
but they are nowhere near of what people
can do so far and it's not quite clear
how much work needs to be done to extend
these systems into what people can do.
It could be that it's very simple.
It could be that it's going to take a
lot of research,
the dire view,
and this was more the traditional view
is that human minds have a lot of also
going our complexity that you need to
build a lot of functionality into it,
like in Minsky Society of mind to get to
all the tricks that people are up to.
And if that is the case then it might
take a very long time.
I had to do,
we have,
we created all these different financial
mechanisms,
but I don't think that it's going to be
so dire because our genome is very short
and most of that codes for the single
cell,
very little of it codes for the brain.
And I think a sale is much more
complicated than a brain.
A brain is probably largely self
organizing and build,
not like clockwork,
but like a couple of Chino.
So you'll mix the right ingredients and
then you let it percolate and then forms
a particular kind of structure.
So I do think because nature of pulls it
off pretty well in most of the cases
that,
um,
even though brain probably needs more
complexity than a Cappuccino,
dramatically more,
it's going to be much simpler than
building a very complicated machine like
a cell.